c'est un rêve de petite fille qui
devient en quelques coups de nageoires
réalité
mais pour que la magie opère il faut
d'abord se transformer en sirène et ça
ça demande quelques efforts
pour enfiler cette nageoires en tissu
très moulante c'est au sol que ça se
passe et non sans quelques difficultés
là je me sens un peu limité dans mes
mouvements il était agréable parce que
700 chevaux et là il fait pas très chaud
quand même deux heures par semaine elles
font de cette piscine leur terrain de
jeu et d'entraînement le mouvement lundi
cordelle
juste on évite de plier les genoux place
que l'intro mélissa a créé ce club
l'année dernière pour partager sa
passion avec d'autres créatures marines
g
une envie d'être une sirène au début et
puis j'ai demandé à la mairie si je
pouvais venir en sirène et on m'a dit
que j'étais la quatrième personne ne
demandera demander ça et donc il fallait
mieux créer un club donc je me suis dit
bon ok allons-y donc manger comme si
rennes avec moi donc c'est trop fait
pratiquer la nage avec une queue de
sirène sa porte un nom le maire mais une
discipline née aux etats-unis et
popularisée par internet à partir de
2010 en france elle est affiliée à la
fédération française de sports
sous-marins elle a ses clubs ses écoles
et même ces rencontres mais on centre
val de loire le club d'orléans et le
seul alors qu'elle y vient toutes les
semaines de bourges pour retrouver ses
copines de bassar ont
laissé y ont une nageoire à l'heure d'un
petit couteau sur terre
et puis je me suis dit ni en fait
c'est intéressant j'ai merdé sinon l'eau
donc une fois en fut privé j'ai essayé
puis j'ai accroché direct
à mi chemin entre le loisir et le sport
le maire meding permet de travailler
tout le corps jambes bras abdos fessiers
et apnée
c'est sympa d'avoir la morale parce que
du coup on est obligé d'avoir les gens
me connaissent a fait utiliser travail
et de tout cela et on se déplace d'une
autre manière sous l'eau douce est
intéressant et puis le côté culturel
fait à ses fins et colorés se sent pas
et ce réseau
il faut passer ce cadre je vais avoir
l'air ridicule franchement entre nous on
n'y pense pas et puis là c'est vraiment
une bonne ambiance
mélissa et ses sirènes espèrent voir
leur tout jeune club évolue et se
professionnaliser et pourquoi pas même
conquérir d'autres bassins de la région